what an exciting time to be a fan of the
division franchise I'll admit the
division day stream was a bit shorter
than I was expecting but when you really
break it down there was a lot packed
into it and I'm going to expand on most
of this over the next few videos however
this video is just going to be a quick
summary of what the stream covered
firstly I'm not gonna lie I almost
totaled this video NG in day because
this is how you guys made me feel after
the stream finished I was absolutely
bombarded all over social media with
kind words from fans of the game
developers and even a couple of fellow
content creators you know the ones I
haven't managed to upset over the last
couple of years I can honestly say I've
never felt so appreciated for a job that
it was asked to do seriously I'm still
smiling while I'm writing this so a mess
of heartfelt thank you to everyone who
reached out to me and left comments
hopefully the devs and my accountant
aren't watching but I would have totally
done all this for free I love this stuff
and had a great time working with the
2-3 Studios towards the outcome of that
short segment and it feels good to be
able to put something towards the future
of this franchise in the community and I
feel like I'm one step closer to
fulfilling my dream of being featured in
a video game Yannick Lauren you know you
need a character with an awkward kiwi
accent I don't care if you kill it off
after one scene I'll retire and die a
happy man
Palo please be kind when the character
modeling though I'm the father of three
young kids and the dead board is in full
swing these days anyway if you haven't
already clicked off the video let's
crack into the summary of The Division
day stream
for the division 2 they announced the
year 5 roadmap featuring Seasons The
Descent game mode and incursion and a
DLC
season 1 Broken Wings is scheduled to be
out in early June and this will include
The Descent game mode and apparel event
and a new Manhunt of which they are
saying will have a bit of a Twist in the
way they play out I'm not exactly sure
what that means but I think a lot of
people will be happy to see a change
we'll also be seeing something that
spans across the first two seasons
called Castle rebuild
I have a feeling that this will be
similar to what we had to do when
setting up the base of operations in the
post office and the White House
when we first got to each of these
buildings there were people we had to
recruit and rescue in order to have
certain areas become constructed and
unlocked
it's probably important to mention that
there is a pts running as we speak where
you can test out some of the new gear
and even The Descent game mode
so you don't need to wait until June you
can jump in and try out the new Rouge
light mode
season 2 is called puppeteers and other
than the Manhunt and the apparel event
it'll also include something called
incursion
in the division one incursions were kind
of like mini raids essentially they were
a long Mission with light raid mechanics
editing there were only a maximum of
four players and there was matchmaking
because learning the curve behind the
mechanics wasn't so steep I look forward
to this because I really like the
incursions in the division one
as far as the story goes I'm looking
forward to season three Vanguard we will
be going back to New York for the
holidays and there will be a holiday
event does this mean snow
but also we'll be finding out more about
Aaron Kina and his Rogues something I
feel has really been lacking up until
now
season four Black Diamond this season
has the largest news of the stream I
don't think anyone was expecting to see
a DLC this year this means new zones new
main missions and a new in-game
structure
I'm going to talk more about this soon
but the image is certainly a familiar
looking Bridge it looks like we could be
crossing the river from Southern
Manhattan in season four
unfortunately there wasn't any huge news
regarding Resurgence other than the
upcoming test phase so make sure you're
all signed up
we were given a lot more detail on
Heartland including a new cinematic that
I'll play soon but summing up Heartland
is a free to play PVE VP survival
extraction game mode I see a lot of
people calling this a battle royale but
it really isn't it's more like cod DMZ
or tarkov with a hint of division
survival
the base of operations is loaded in a
skating rink and for the first time the
base of operations will be a fully open
shared space from here you can prepare
your daily bag
every time you extract you bring back
all materials and gear and can use them
to prepare for the next operation
every Excursion has a day and night
cycle during the day you can collect and
do missions to help rebuild the base of
operations
at night there are rogue agents and PVP
is enabled however there are much
greater Rewards
through the creating of the quick recap
timeline I was given far more
information that I really can't talk
about but what I will say is that I'm
far more excited about what this game is
bringing along than it was before
there is an upcoming PC closed beta so
register now at the divisionhotlines.com
also if you're selected you'll be able
to invite five people along with you so
uh you know keep me in mind guys
welcome to Silver Creek
a sweet little town in Middle America
you know the kind
pumpkin patches Apple highs and the best
damn cup of coffee you'll ever have
Silver Creek was perfect up until it
wasn't
the green poison changed everything for
everyone
started in New York on Black Friday the
biggest shopping day of the year they
called it the dollar flu because it
spread on money the virus knew No
Boundaries no matter where it hit the
bodies piled up and when it spread to
Silver Creek the result was the same
death
I'm division agent Mackenzie Reed
originally from Kansas I was stationed
in Boston when the hit the fan
after Black Friday
I left Boston and came to Silver Creek
looking for Killian Tower my commander
he was my commander until recently for
reasons unknown he disavowed the
division and is now a rogue agent
Killian betrayed my team and murdered
them he gunned them down and fled no
clues no motive only a bloody Trail for
me to follow
that trail has led me to Silver Creek
I wasn't prepared for what I found I
wanted answers but all I got was more
questions why is the virus different
here why did Killian murder the team he
proudly commanded and why is he amassing
an army of Reapers in Silver Creek
everything I've seen tells me that
silver Creeks at the heart of something
big
I can't do this alone agent
other random things we'll be seeing is a
new whip tune that will follow a
division agent who is working as a
teacher in Houston Texas
no mentions of other novels at this
point so I'll just remind you that you
need to get Thomas parrott's books we're
starting to see some crossovers between
them and the game's story now plus
they're awesome and I want to see more
we'll also be getting some new action
figures Brian Johnson and Caleb Dunn I'm
definitely going to need these for the
collection
and last but not least there will be
cross game vanity drops playing the
different titles will reward you with
drops in the other titles
I really like this idea and I hope they
continue to expand on it
then at the very end of the stream some
guy with a weird voice played a mini
timeline recap like I said this was just
a quick summary of what was shown I'm
already expanding on some of this with a
few ideas of where I think things like
the story could be going
but for now I really need to jump in and
try out descent I mean during the stream
they showed that my team has topped the
leaderboard I better make sure to keep
up the illusion
thanks for watching and I'll catch you
in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]